Performing
"Hold Me Like a Grudge"
from their new album,
"So Much (for) Stardust,"
give it up for Fall Out Boy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Glass shatters ]
♪♪
-♪ When you ask how I've been ♪
♪ I know you mean well,
I know you mean well ♪
♪ Who am I dialing tonight? ♪
♪ That's a bummer ♪
♪ Thaw out my freezer, burn
feelings for twenty summers ♪
♪ I'm just a cherub riding
comets through the night sky ♪
♪ Screaming at the stars
like night lights ♪
♪ And I love my life,
love my life ♪
♪ Running middle fingers
through the red lights ♪
♪ And I guess I'm getting older
'cause I'm less pissed ♪
♪ When I can't get
onto the guest list ♪
♪ To the end of the world,
the end of the world ♪
♪ Fever-dream tangerine sweat
when I get down, down ♪
♪ Silent killers are these years
coming like waves ♪
♪ You put the "fun"
into dysfunction ♪
♪ Hold me,
hold me like a grudge ♪
♪ The world is always spinning,
and I can't keep up, whoa ♪
♪ Faster and faster,
can't do it on my own ♪
♪ Part-time soulmate,
full-time problem, oh ♪
♪ So hold me like a grudge ♪
♪♪
♪ Hold me like a grudge,
yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Hold me like a grudge ♪
♪♪
♪ I guess somehow
we made it back ♪
♪ With a few dreams of ours
still intact ♪
♪ I am a diamond on the inside,
just add the pressure ♪
♪ Know it's inside me, but I got
no map to my own treasure ♪
♪ I'm just a cherub riding
comets through the night sky ♪
♪ Screaming at the stars
like night lights ♪
♪ And I love my life,
love my life ♪
♪ Running middle fingers
through the red lights ♪
♪ And I guess I'm getting older
'cause I'm less pissed ♪
♪ We didn't make to your
year-end best list ♪
♪ End of the world,
the end of the world ♪
♪ Fever-dream tangerine sweat
when I get down, down ♪
♪ Silent killers are these years
coming like waves ♪
-♪ You put the "fun"
into dysfunction ♪
-♪ Hold me,
hold me like a grudge ♪
♪ The world is always spinning,
and I can't keep up, whoa ♪
♪ Faster and faster,
can't do it on my own ♪
♪ Part-time soulmate,
full-time problem, yeah ♪
♪ So hold me like a grudge ♪
♪♪
♪ Hold me like a grudge,
yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Hold me like a grudge ♪
♪♪
♪ I thought I knew better,
I thought it would get better ♪
♪ I figured somehow by now
I would have got it together ♪
♪ But if you put your, put your
heart in it, heart in it ♪
♪ Then we'll do more
than just get by together ♪
♪ Now call you up and demand
you have no fun without me ♪
♪ I'm like a storm on the
horizon, storm on the horizon ♪
-♪ You put the "fun"
into dysfunction ♪
-♪ Hold me,
hold me like a grudge ♪
♪ The world is always spinning,
and I can't keep ♪
♪ I can't keep up ♪
♪ Faster and faster,
can't do it on my own ♪
♪ Part-time soulmate,
full-time problem, yeah ♪
♪ Hold me like a grudge ♪
♪ Oh, ohh ♪
♪ Hold, hold, hold ♪
♪ Hold me like a grudge ♪
♪ Hold, hold, hold me like ♪
♪ Hold me like a,
hold me like a grudge ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]